telling it like it is the pittsburgh
steelers don't play perfectly but their
record
is perfect 10 and oh the first time in
franchise history as mike tarico
mentioned last night the 18th time in
the super bowl era that we have had a
team reach 10 and oh and if it was the
patriots
with 10 wins and no losses
and six games left the specific six
games left that the steelers have left
it would be the headline of every sports
show it was we would have come on air
talking about can the patriots go you're
right you're right the steelers the most
overlooked disregarded and irrelevant
10-0 team of the 18 that have ever been
10-0 and i can't say that with authority
even though i really don't know there
probably have been some other 10-0 teams
that people were like eh but that's the
attitude with this deal it's just kind
of like
and there it's just a sense they're
eventually going to lose and every week
they just show up chris and they keep
winning yeah i mean you're you're right
like
off the top of my head just thinking
about it too i i mean i i agree with you
mike i think there's less to do and less
of a big deal being made about them as
10-0 as at least i can never remember
you know i really can't i mean i feel
like we were making a way bigger deal
last year with the patriots being like
eight no and things like that definitely
and what is it i mean what exactly i
i've been thinking about this you know
just like why why is that and is it just
because
like the offense can look ugly at times
and it's just it's not exactly like a
well-oiled machine and then the sudden
it has like this flurry of like
awesomeness and then it goes back to
average i don't know really what it is
or why but you're right it's just
nationally they're not quite getting the
credit you would normally see as a 10-0
team
i think one of the factors
is
that they are not blowing everyone out
the way the last undefeated team did the
patriots in 2007. where it was
globetrotters washington generals almost
every week and if it was one of those
occasions where the game was just kind
of close it was like whoa whoa whoa hold
on they almost took down goliath and uh
it it
all of these games not all of them but
most of them are a lot of us and even
yesterday the 2073 finish it looked
early on like the jaguars were there to
play the jaguars were up three nothing
they did an ill-advised onside kick
although if it worked it would have been
genius that's kind of how it goes for
on-site kicks but uh you know the
steelers eventually pulled away from
them but but they're just kind of doing
it quietly methodically and we'll see
how many more weeks they can continue to
do now starting thursday night against
the baltimore with you i raised this
question
are they not made as a big of a deal
because
they wouldn't be favored if they had to
play the chiefs one one versus one i
mean
that does that play into that
that may have something to do with right
that the lone unbeaten team is not the
best right team or at least not
as the best team right yeah that the
chiefs still have that aura and hey it
may be the chiefs that ultimately hang
the first loss on the pittsburgh
steelers and we can only hope that they
get a chance to face each other
presumably hopefully ideally in the afc
championship game but that is still to
come as the season continues to unfold
superlatives time
what do you have for us first
christopher how about 1.21 gigawatts
sin oh i like it oh baby cause watson
was on fire my man d sean watson
i mean
he was on fire yesterday i know that
wasn't the marquee game at one o'clock
wait a minute wait a minute what does
1.21 gigawatts you got me all excited
that you're going to have some great
back to the future reference
being
he was electric he was electric deshaun
watson 1.21 jiggle watson that's what i
said okay it's my superlative segment
back off all right
two thumbs down two middle fingers up oh
thank you well i feel like every time i
talk about desean watson i end up
singing the song so i had to give
something else there and i didn't want
to go like houston we have liftoff
i couldn't do that either saying that's
okay all right but either way all right
he was unreal yesterday he really was
you know
i know we talked about in the pregame
show coach junjie talked about it so
much too just
the the patriots always take away what
you do best and they couldn't stop
desean watson yesterday you know and
like i was saying it wasn't the marquee
game at one o'clock but for those who
didn't see it or want to see it or
whatever just go back and watch the
highlights and watch desean watson's
best throws of the game it'll kind of
tell you everything you need to know
tight coverage scrambling
you know people around him in the pocket
just guy open by four inches he throws
lasers in there he was unstoppable
yesterday he was on his game it was as
good as i saw him play all year long and
uh we haven't talked about him a lot
he's been playing amazing football he's
on a bad team then we know that but
yesterday he uh showed his worth for
sure
there was a report yesterday i think it
was from espn that owner cal mcnair has
already consulted with desean watson
regarding the next coach and
that's a controversial subject because
they didn't consult with aaron rodgers
before they hired matt leflore you
typically don't talk to the quarterback
about the coach but you know what
when you have a quarterback that
possibly is getting to the point where
he's had enough
if there's a bone you can throw if
there's a thing you can do a decision
you can make a relationship you can
spark where he's going to be happy
maybe you do it because clearly he's all
they have now credit to j.j watt he had
four deflected passes yesterday of cam
newton back to the future for jj watt
1.21 jiggle watts i got you there
eventually right but but uh other than
than desean and the games when jj can
spin it back to the future they got
nothing cupboards bear and and as you
said last night excellent observation
bill belichick wants to take away what
the opposing offense does best
you still sometimes can't take it away
even when you know it's desean watson
and and he was and i always worry about
him when i see him run and embrace
contact because he's kind of wiry yeah
he's not thick like a russell wilson and
i just worry he's going to get himself
injured again but man he took on a
couple of patriots and just forced his
way into the end zone
and and and that to me cried out i'm
sick of this
expert deleted right attitude like
enough of this season i'm enough of 2020
it's kind of like what we all would like
to do to 2020. that's what he did to the
patriots on that play no he did he was
he seemed like on a mission from the
get-go yesterday he did and yeah running
over devon mccourty that way i mean you
don't see that happen too often but uh
he he is just such a phenomenal talent
the way he can move you know he's a top
level thrower of the football he makes
good decisions
and you know we talked a little last
week we talked about the quarterback
rankings and all that you know he he
wants to stay in the pocket and throw
the football he wants to dice you up
that way
and that's what makes him so special and
cool that's where i think you know him
and mahomes are special because they
want to throw it and and carve you up
with their right arms but when they're
like oh nobody else is open oh i i can
rely on this unbelievable ability to get
away from people and make moves now and
that's where it becomes unstoppable in
games like yesterday where the patriots
don't have one marquee
you know pass rusher in their front
seven and they just couldn't contain him
it didn't matter so he made runs throws
whatever he wanted but it was pretty
awesome
yeah and look it makes it even more
impressive because
they're not playing for anything and and
i was thinking about an
i won't be back award for the death of
the terminator because lost in what
watson did good is what the patriots did
not do good and the patriots bile
appearances are done although i guess
they could still run the table and sneak
in i don't see that happening one of the
reasons why it's going to be difficult
for the patriots is because of and i
remember this old song from jim croce in
the 70s bad bad leroy brown these are
the bad bad cleveland browns and not bad
in a bad way bad in a good way they are
going to go 10-6
write it down they have been on that
formula all year long they win the games
they should they lose the games they
should and when you look at the balance
of the schedule
it works out to 10 and six and look hey
the way the ravens are going maybe
they'll beat baltimore and maybe it'll
be 11 and 5. but if it's 10 and 6 chris
then the question is is it the 2007
browns who went 10 and 6 and didn't make
it or is it going to be more like the
browns who did make it in 2002 i think
they were eleven and five when they made
it in two thousand twenty two
only time the reconstituted browns have
made it to the postseason in
22 seasons they've made it once and they
lost to the steelers in the wild card
round but you know it's not pretty it is
boring as i mentioned last night but
it's effective they're getting it done
they had the pick six of carson wentz
that really started things off but even
after that it just kind of felt sluggish
and plodding and then nick chubb has the
big run where he slams the guy to the
ground with the stiff arm and they got
the shot of baker mayfield uh very giddy
over what nick chubb was able to do and
and they just get it done they take your
best punch they counter punch and they
eventually win as long as it's a game
they should win they they are not going
to get very far though if they can't
flip
one of these games that they should
lose into a game that they win and we
talked about the steelers potentially
going 16-0
the last man standing in the way of an
undefeated season
the same team that delivered the last
loss to the browns in 2017 a game that
corey coleman if he doesn't drop the
pass remember that yeah the browns win
that game against the steelers right now
it's it's the other way around just a
few years later where it could be the
browns the last chance to keep the
steelers from going 16-0 yeah there's
there's a lot to like about the browns i
mean i mean first off i mean was it
three games in a row and these just
horrible elements and you know to their
credit i know they lost the game against
the raiders but you know houston last
week this game here they don't make any
mistakes you know they're playing the
right way which leads itself to like
kind of an ugly boring football game to
what you're saying you know they're not
going to let their offense ruin the game
they weren't you know they they seem to
understand the big picture of how the
game needs to be played that day
according to their opponent or whatever
else and stefanski's phenomenal of being
patient with the run game they really
don't put a lot on baker mayfield's
shoulders and their defense has just
progressively gotten better throughout
the year too and they make a few plays
here and there so you know i like them i
don't know if i'm ready to go like play
off football team quite yet i don't know
about that um
and i think yes there's three losses on
their schedule possibly and listen even
the new york giants the way they're
playing i don't think that'll be easy
either but uh there's still a lot to be
proud of there for a seven and three
football team who looks like right now
you know they're gonna be getting in for
sure
um all right you good with that one
well one last thing i wanted to say i
mean they're 2-0 coming out of the buy
they have jacksonville next week and
then the real test the the opportunity
to win a game they should lose
back-to-back titans ravens that's good
and the ravens game a monday nighter
december 14 in cleveland that would be a
great test for the cleveland browns yeah
that's what the the bottom of this afc
playoff picture i mean a lot of these
teams play each other and there's a lot
of cross over here so that's going to be
you know there's still meat left on the
bone you know for lack of a better way
to say here as far as you know tennessee
cleveland las vegas at seven and three
seven three six and four and of course
baltimore and miami aren't out of the
hunt uh we know that
i that's where i think
i wanna go next was just you know the
pump the brakes award you know and that
goes to the miami dolphins and just the
way they played yesterday pumped the
brakes on all of it you know there we
were thinking man denver broncos been
all over the place drew drew lock you
know bruised ribs he's been inconsistent
all of these things surely miami will go
in and control the football game well
you know denver did something we haven't
seen so far yet with it they didn't let
like the special teams and defense beat
them that's what we've seen so far
through through the tua era is the other
phases of football have been very very
impressive and we haven't seen chua have
to deliver
and yesterday vic fangio came with a
game plan not only was it great on the
offensive side of the ball running the
ball and doing things like that but tua
was obviously
flustered and confused with what he was
seeing you know yeah he got sacked
certainly but there was a lot of sack
and pressure too
of a guy that's a young quarterback that
looked like he didn't know what he was
seeing downfield or nobody was open i'll
be excited to go back and watch the film
and see what it was but it certainly
wasn't a good look you know we talked
those two weeks right mike where two it
was screens bootlegs one-on-one jump
balls they kind of took away that
yesterday and now this is the next phase
and not to downgrade two or anything but
just it's another phase in his
development as a quarterback and we saw
yesterday he had a few bumps in the road
and that's why he was bench late in the
game for ryan ryan fitzpatrick
yeah i mean what happened yesterday is
kind of what i thought could have
happened last week yeah game against the
chargers
and it yeah we can't and we didn't go
all in because we get caught up in the
story and tua is such a nice guy and we
want him to do well but we've kind of
been on the lookout for this moment
where somebody's going to come up with
something that he's not going to be able
to counter that brian flores isn't going
to be able to overcome change the
offensive coordinator won't be able to
solve and that's what vic fangio did we
didn't expect it from the broncos
yesterday because we don't expect
anything from the broncos currently but
that's what made it more stunning so
tool was benched for ryan fitzpatrick
who ultimately became fitztragic who
ultimately will take a seat next week
for tua and you know usually what the
prevailing mood would be among media and
fans is you don't
yank a young quarterback out of the
lineup and put it back in and take him
out and put him back in and that's going
to hurt his confidence and it's going to
hurt his development i
hey brian flores knows what he's doing
he's done enough with that team
in a year and a little more than a half
to get me to say
yeah if you believe it'll work
i have no reason to doubt you coach
flores
agreed he's he's pulled all the right
strings pushed all the right buttons and
you know we've talked about this too
before
if your top 10 pick
can't handle a little scrutiny and being
benched and being put back down there
then damn he ain't your guy he's not
your guy move on then so
uh and i think to what he realizes
because brian flores has great people
skills and knows how to read people and
everything like that he realizes this
guy is able to you know take this as a
learning experience grow it wasn't their
day it certainly wasn't there was a good
game plan like we talked about with
denver denver's denver's offense stayed
on the field a whole lot i mean it was
the same running play all game long the
broncos just pulled the weak side guard
kicked out the defense end and lindsey
and gordon just ran up the middle
constantly so it wasn't all on to us
certainly but uh it was the first time
we saw the game in his short career to
this point kind of be put on him where
he went okay they're they're not going
to be able to pull it off with
interceptions and block punts and punt
returns today he's going to have to make
some throws and plays and he kind of hit
a buzz saw there and it wasn't real
pretty
all right next one for me and i don't
think i've ever done this
for a team that didn't play at all this
weekend but you know what the bears may
be at their best when they don't play
the bears are back baby here's why
packers
lose
vikings lose
lions
lose
bears win and yeah i may be
a full transparency hyping our sunday
night game a little bit prematurely but
next sunday night make it interesting
packers bears get together and and
here's the thing
packers are seven and three
bears are five and five if if matt nagy
and company can just kind of grope
around in the dark and get lucky and
find the reset button whether it's nick
foles whether it's mitchell trubisky
whoever it may be at quarterback
they can get back into this thing
they they they are they are still very
much alive and the fact that the
cardinals yeah
bit of an opening hey i do have i do
have a complaint though whoever did the
graphic the vikings are four and six so
i think they should be on the in the
hunt oh they're giving
papers
we don't know what you want anymore
we've given up with you in the vikings
you're so all over the place who knows
what you want anymore you love him you
hate him you love him you hate him now
he wants him in the playoffs who knows
jeez
oh my gosh
i do have a message for you but there's
a priest that used to be here in town
who grew up in minneapolis he's a big
vikings fan he was over to watch a game
the thursday night or last year when
washington and the vikings got together
he told me to tell you
that he has received the annulment
papers and he has denied my request for
an annulment with the vikings oh so if a
priest says it then that's that's it
it's it's binding okay and i can do it
fine you're stuck kirk cousins is your
quarterback buddy here we go you and the
vikings and that's the truth too that's
not just some dumb joke i'm trying
that's that's actually true i got the
text message from the priest on friday
to tell you the priest
denies the anomaly okay good all right
god stuck you're you're stuck all right
well that's that's you know i don't know
you made that choice a long time ago you
should have to live with it anyways i i
understand that um all right what the
hell are we talking about oh the bears
that is unbelievable though and
especially wait with five and five
and you said all the teams that lost
arizona that lost their sitting there at
six and four and arizona's got some
tough games coming up here to where they
could easily it's patriots it's rams
coming up the next two weeks they could
lose both of those football games you
sit there and go man the bears as ugly
as they have looked they certainly are
in the thick of things and if they could
pull off some magic on sunday night
against aaron rodgers and company yeah
who knows what happens there
um
man man i'm gonna go my next one is bad
mamma jammas that's what they are we
haven't talked about it we talked a
little but bad man pajamas that's what
the steelers got they just got bad man
pajamas all over the field that's so
that's all i look at oh you know all
defense is bending whoa jacksonville's
moving the ball
oh sack oh interception oh you know
force fumble oh offense looks bad oh
claypool touchdown deontay johnson bomb
i mean it that's where i think it's
almost like we don't give them the
credit because there's moments where we
just go
it doesn't look that dominant but they
always make the play and hang around and
it's just you know that's where i give
mike tomlin credit you know
the gm
kevin colbert credit just with
everything they've done there they have
so many guys that are difference makers
on both sides of the field where yeah
even when they hit stale moments or the
defensive scheme might not be i mean the
scheme itself might not be hitting on
all cylinders it just doesn't matter
they have guys that we just go we're
better than you our guy's better than
your guy we're going to make a play and
destroy just jumps out to me about the
steelers the interceptions by the
safeties the big plays by the receivers
it's just amazing how many studs they
got out there we really are going into
the wayback machine today between my
reference to the stephen stills song
love the one you're with bad bad leroy
brown she's a bad man pajama i mean
we're we're we are uh
there are there is a demographic out
there that is wondering what in the hell
are these two guys talking about but but
sure i mean the steelers really that
that's that you know when you when you
start breaking it down and looking at
who they have on that defense it it is
phenomenal yeah um and uh it's it's back
to where we started the idea that that
why is this team not garnering more
respect and i think the best explanation
is the one that you articulated the idea
that we still would
in a game between the chiefs and the
steelers not we not me
collectively the sense would be that the
chiefs are going to win
i learned
last week and this makes it easy for me
the rest of the way i heard you
yesterday
saying that you're you're probably or at
least thinking about picking the ravens
on thursday night because they're going
to be desperate and i started to think
that too
i've already cast my lot i will not pick
against the steelers again this year
because the two times i did they blew
out the browns and they blew out the
bengals so
i'm on board they they've just
and i still think it goes back to last
year when they when they
didn't have ben roethlisberger and they
found that magic where they stayed
competitive in every game no matter how
bad the quarterback play was i really do
think that's helped them and it's made
them into a powerhouse this season and
uh it's fun to watch
unless you're the team that is playing
the pittsburgh steelers that week all
right do we have do we have time for
another one i don't know that i have
another one okay we have time for
another one now i have to find another
one how about uh
let's let's give pj walker some credit
this is the bring back the xfl award we
we finally have a guy who played in one
of these
minor leagues right last year the aaf
had some guys that trickled to the nfl
and they never did anything we saw what
garrett gilbert can or can't do at the
nfl
level
he was the aaf's darling a couple of
years ago and now this week we saw the
xfl's darling and pj walker and no teddy
bridgewater matt rule matt rule
already has mastered
injury information obfuscation
christian mccaffrey oh he's day to day
sure he is teddy bridgewater i don't
have any updates sure you don't he's day
to day sure he is they took it right up
until 90 minutes before kickoff teddy
bridgewater scratched pj walker comes in
they shut out the lines now the defense
had a lot to do with that but hey
for a guy in his first nfl start who was
picked off of the xfl scrap heap
reunited with matt rule i mean if i'm if
i'm david tepper the owner of the team
i'm thinking man i'm
paying a lot to this bridgewater guy pj
walker dollar for dollar pj walker's
better
well dollar for dollar i well yeah okay
dollar for dollar and he's got a lot of
he's got ability he does i mean there's
no doubt you know he really never loses
control of the football pretty good
athlete i don't think like the skill set
is it probably is better than
bridgewater really honestly mike he just
hasn't played as much football you know
doesn't have that experience that way
but we saw yesterday i mean he is
certainly capable of moving the ball and
his two interceptions which were his two
worst plays of the day obviously were in
the end zone you know where they move
the ball down the field effectively on
those drives too i mean but so there's a
lot to like and you said matt rule he's
already mastered life in the nfl
altogether and that was embarrassing by
the lions i mean there you are sitting
in like oh we got a chance here we're
four and five we might be able to get
back in this thing and then just to lay
an egg like that you know on the road
against yeah a tough carolina team but
not a great team nothing like that uh
that that pretty much puts a fork in the
detroit lions for the year and that ends
that
renewed calls widespread calls for matt
patricia to be fired basically the
argument and i saw this from dave
burkett of the deferred free press if
sheila ford hamp doesn't do it now then
everything she said last year about what
she expects in 2020 was false
i don't know that i'll go quite that far
i'll look at it and say it was just one
game but it was not a pretty game it was
the first shutout of the matt stafford
era which is saying a lot for a team
that has typically found a way to score
points but when you don't have kenny
galladay you don't have deandre swift
you don't have danny amendola it makes
it harder to move the ball and score
points but kudos to the panthers at four
and seven uh they have uh continued to
outperform what we thought every
building team would do
because look at the jets a rebuilding
team that can't win a game panthers in
the same boat but they have been able to
be competitive and win plenty of games
all right do you have another one um i
mean
i was going to say something about
justin herbert you know because of just
the way yesterday and we haven't talked
about joe burrow because i don't even
want to talk about it because i i feel
bad
uh but like with justin herbert i almost
wanted to give him like the roy award i
just think like with the facts of how he
played yesterday joe burrow getting hurt
man rookie of the year
is in in the in the sights of justin
herbert and what i liked yesterday just
to hit on that game i mean that was the
first time i felt like they played
through the pass game first they came
out we're going to throw the football
and then they ran off it and they're
more dangerous that way and herbert you
know again i know a lot of people aren't
watching chargers jets but holy crapola
batman i mean it's just one unreal throw
after another uh and i just can't say
how impressed i am not don't necessarily
love his haircut i've seen better there
but his throwing his right arm is really
damn special
his haircut doesn't look much different
than yours
yeah so i don't like it he's trying to
copy me give him that look
uh i i'm i'm stunned i'm stunned i'm
shocked and i'm saddened that you would
mention joe burrows departure for the
season and we're both heartbroken by
that and uh we wish him all the best and
we hope he's back for week one of next
year
how can you talk about rookie of the
year without mentioning
your guy
chase claypool the first receiver of the
super era to have 10 touchdowns in his
first 10 games as a rookie only worth
but you know i thought randy marsh
surely had 10 touchdowns in 10 games
nope he had seven he had 10 in his final
six
but he only had seven in his first ten
right and chase claypool has 10
touchdowns in 10 games it is amazing and
there was a little kerfuffle last week a
little dust up a little frank is a
little brouhaha because espn had their
top 10 rookies and
chase claypool was not on the list well
i think he'll be on everyone's list now
and and you know it just fits to bring
it all back to where we started yes the
steelers are just bad pajamas i know
you're right they're overlooked and yeah
because the stats aren't gonna ring true
like he's not gonna be a 80 or 90
reception guy and he's probably not
going to get to a thousand yards but for
some of those guys and rookies and
receivers who might have more stats than
them i would just go i'd take chase
claypool because when he touches the
ball it's game-changing type plays it's
touchdowns you know and it's all the
other you know things he does for the
offense because he is a weapon where
coverage has to worry about him down the
field but my i you know i'll stand by
what mike taurico and people at notre
dame heard me say the last few years
when i was there i've never really seen
a receiver built like chase claypool he
is one of the freakiest human beings
i've seen in my life you know brandon
marshall whatever you want he's right up
there with as good as i've seen at that
receiver position and i'm just you know
10 touchdowns am i surprised yeah a
little bit but i'm not shocked that he's
coming in the nfl and and made a name
for himself
and we do need to mention what happened
to joe borough yesterday he didn't see
it you don't want to see it i saw the
replay one time and and that's that's
all you know all you need to know acl
torn more knee damage feared mri today
joe burrow made it clear with the tweet
from late yesterday afternoon thanks for
all the love can't get rid of me that
easy see you next year he won't be
playing again this season we can only
hope he's good to go next year that
plant leg is what got crushed uh in the
in the game against washington and uh
here's hoping he's back and good as new
because he was
awesome awesome uh so far this season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports